[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
et
dans un village vivait deux frères l'un
était riche l'autre pauvre le riz
j'étais célibataire
le pauvre était marié leriche ne
travaillait pas le pauvre était ouvrier
agricole il n'avait pas de maison mais
vivait avec sa femme chez le fermier qui
l'employait tandis que le riche lui
avait une grande et belle maison
le pauvre est gentil avec tout le monde
aussi des gens du village là mais bien
le riche lui était avare de sorte que
les gens ne l'aiment et guerre mais avec
l'hiver
le pauvre ne veut plus de travail il
avait demandé à son frère l'hospitalité
leriche voulu bien les bergers avec sa
femme mais à la condition qu'ils soient
couchés dès 9 heures du soir
le pauvre accepta et le jour même il
s'installait avec sa femme pendant trois
mois ils vécurent tounsi ils prenaient
leur repas ensemble et après le dîner
sitôt la table desservi le pauvre et sa
femme monter ce coup chez le riche lui
payait très tard jusqu'à une heure
avancée de la nuit
casse pour faire ton frère site hors
effet ce que vous allez chez lui
mais la femme voulait pourtant savoir un
soir elle descendit doucement l'escalier
pieds nus et sans lumière
elle s'approcha sans faire du bruit et
elle lit son beau frère assis devant une
petite boîte en fer d'où il tirait des
pièces d'or qu'il empile qu'elle remonte
à et dit à son mari
ton frère raconte de l'or et pourquoi
point c'est son nom après tout un matin
la femme du pauvre des 110 pour un hymne
du feu et faire le café le riche étaient
encore couchés
et elle s'aperçut sous 2 khatami
[Musique]
en
qu'est ce que t'en après le couple a
lâché le notaire leriche n'ayant pas
d'enfant tous ces biens revenait aux
pauvres mais il restait la boîte de
pièces d'or
un soir qu'il l'a cherchée dans toute la
maison fantôme du riche leur a paru
allez vous en disiez vous n'aurez pas
mono effrayer le parti ils achetèrent
une petite maison et vécurent à l'abri
du besoin
plus tard il ya un petit garçon et
l'année d'après une petite fille
tous les dimanches après midi il allait
se promener on n'est pas du côté du
cimetière
surtout entre et jamais dans la maison
de vente ou joe pia il se fâchait mais
voilà qu'un beau soir de printemps les
enfants furent surpris par l'orage il
pleuvait fort très fort
le ciel était noir et plein d claire
entrons dans cette maison le petit
garçon avait bien reconnu la maison de
l'oncle mais il faisait tellement
mauvais qu'il entre air ils trouvèrent
mali se déshabillait récent dormir il
fut réveillé par une grosse voix
qu'est-ce qu'on veut d'ici pas dans le
dieu je note que pour le mettre à l'abri
y est colabor qui êtes vous lorsqu'il
dire leur nom le fantôme s'écria alors
comme ça vous êtes menneveux oui mon
oncle à je comprends tout maintenant
c'est votre père qui vous en voyez ici
pour m'espionner et me pour me voler mon
corps doit vous vous trompez mon nom je
vous assure c'est pas fin à l'eau
sortait l'issue les deux enfants
allaient sortir quand le fantôme les
arts est à jamais
bon allez vous voyez bien qu'ils
pleurent encore est resté ici on est
chacun de couverture approchez-vous
échauffez vous
alors le petit garçon s'endormit mais un
éclat de rire le réveil
c'était sa petite soeur car l'oncle
pierre s'était endormi aussi et la
petite fille en avait profité pour
monter sur ses genoux et traversant le
corps impalpable du fantôme elle s'était
assise dans l' oncle pierre ça lui
faisait rire donc le pierre réveiller à
l'instant regarder la mer bouleversé la
petite fille assise dans son vin c'est
donc vrai
je suis un fantôme
tenir
en
demain matin vous donnerez ça à vos
parents
le lendemain il faisait grand jour et
l'oncle avait disparu
mes enfants rentraient chez leurs
parents avec la boîte pleine de pièces
d'or
il ya des gens qui prétendent que cette
nuit là les enfants n'avait fait qu'un
rêve
mais ce qu'il ya de certain c'est que
depuis ce jour le fantôme de l'oncle
pierre n'est plus jamais revenu dans la
vieille maison
[Musique]